CARTER AND DAVID BOSSIE ARE SOME
OF TONIGHT'S LIVE GUESTS.
BUT FIRST TO MY OPENING
STATEMENT.
THEY DECIDE TO TRASH, BELITTLE
AND SHAME THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
FAMILY INCLUDING THE FIRST LADY,
TAKING FUN OF THEIR ACCENT,
MAYOR HAIR, AND THEY DECIDE TO
IGNORE A CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA
ON THE FISA ABUSE SCANDAL AND
THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
SO WHO ARE THEY?
AND WHO DO WE BLAME FOR THE
REPEATED TRASHING OF THE FIRST
LADY.
WHO DO WE BLAME FOR THE REFUSAL
TO HONOR CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENAS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE GROUP TO
BLAME, AND THAT GROUP IS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
HOW DID WE GET SO LOST, HOW IS
IT THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE SO
COMFORTABLE, SO AT EASE HANG IN
EFFIGY THE BLOODY HEAD OUR
PRESIDENT, LAUGHING ABOUT
KILLING HIM IN THE ELEVATOR,
LAUGHING ABOUT BLOWING UP THE
WHITE HOUSE, THREATENING TO BEAT
UP THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S A WHARTON GRADUATE WHO GOT
A 30 OUT OF 30 ON AN ACUTITY
TEST WHEN SEAN PENN AND JOHNNY
DEPP NEVER GOT PAST THE 12th
GRADE.
THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY CAN.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LEARNED THERE
ARE NO CONSEQUENCES, THAT
NOTHING HAPPENS TO THEM WHEN
THEY DO.
BARACK OBAMA ON THE OTHER HAND,
HILLARY CLINTON AND NANCY PELOSI
PROMOTE RESISTANCE AND
OBSTRUCTION.
POLICE ARE TOLD TO STAND DOWN
AND NOT ARREST.
HOLLYWOOD JUMPS IN TRYING TO
BRAINWASH EVERYONE THAT THE
PRESIDENT, REPUBLICANS AND
ANYONE WHO BELIEVES IN LAW AND
IDEOLOGICAL FEDERAL JUDGES
FOLLOW THE NARRATIVE.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP SEEKS TO
REFLECT US ON OUR BORDER BECAUSE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
SWAMPED, THEY CHANNEL IN UNISON
THAT HE'S A RACIST, A FLASH
FLOOD WATCHIST.
THEY DITHER AS TO WHETHER THEY
WANT THEIR BORDER PROTECTED.
IN CASE OF OREGON'S KATE BROWN,
SHE REFUSED BORED PROTECTION AND
REFUSED TO ASSIST OTHER STATES
THREE DAYS AFTER SHE ACCEPTED A
LARGE DONATION FROM GEORGE
SOROS.
HEY, KATE, YOU WEREN'T EVEN IN
THE PICTURE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS MAP.
YOUR STATE ISN'T ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WHERE THE OPERATION IS
BEING CONDUCTED.
DEMOCRATS ARE COMFORTABLE DOING
WHAT THEY DO BECAUSE THEY
LEARNED HOW TO WIELD POWER LIKE